I think the women probably will man up and then we've never forgiven,
which is part of the reason why
it's Rondo
killed all those people.
It's because
he didn't like it.
No one even,
and his cell phone was with something like,
I'm constantly in such a way that what I've learned with rejection and then made
it bigger.
Your comprehension and murderers
and women are prone to reject him.
You have twice as many female ancestors is male ancestors and evolutionary
biology seems quite clear.
The reason that we've diverged from a common ancestor of chimpanzees and human
beings is because chimpanzee females are not sexually selective and human
females are,
and that means that whatever progress we've paid as a species,
assuming what we paid constitutes progress,
has been as a consequence of women to proclivity to reject.
And you might think,
well,
you know,
maybe that's a price worth paying,
but it's not necessarily a price that you want to pay.
If you happen to be one of those bands,
you were constantly be rejected.
Now perhaps to the right attitude to that is,
well,
you should figure out how to retool yourself so that you're not being rejected
by 50% of the population,
which is fairly solid evidence that there might be something about you that's
not exactly like straight and appropriate,
let's say.
But you know,
that's a harsh test,
the harshest of all possible judgements and it's very difficult thing for people
to accept and no one did so,
okay,
so anyways,
he thinks having self conscious and then,
then what happens?
Well,
the next part of the story is a black quantity and so god goes for a walk to the
guard and he's accustomed to walking without them.
But that means to me,
I think it's something like we weren't conceptualized in this talk to some
degree with God represents,
please can this part of the narrative quick going represents that divine
consciousness,
let's say that you partake in that confronts the potential of chaos.
Some transplants actually to walk with that is to be guided by that principle.
You know,
if you're on the street here on path to where you should be in your life,
then natural you do it.
And maybe that requires courage.
It requires you to be forthright.
It requires you to look up into,
to try to make the world a better place rather than a terrible place.
And so out,
these just the customer's doing have him today after he's woken up and become
self conscious,
he hides the,
like the books.
And that's partly why it's comical because you can't hide.
You can't hide from Bush
a Bush.
It's like,
and it doesn't reflect her involve about to intelligence.
This is fraud.
And he's hiding behind a bush and he comes up with three ladies.
Excuse too.
So go ahead and calls officers,
what's up?
What are we supposed to go for a walk?
And then he says,
um,
I make an end to shade.
And God says,
who told you that you were naked?
And this is the terrible part of the story.
Um,
you know,
because eve is often portrayed as the villain,
at least that's the theory,
right?
If you,
if you,
if you regard the biblical stories as part of the patriarchal oppression,
centuries long patriarchal oppression and eve is the bad person who's erupted.
Mankind.
Madden has been severely,
it's complete rubbish because Adam shows his true colors in the second part in
the story because as soon as God calls him who said that you were naked,
what does he mean?
He says he does two things.
He says,
remember that the woman who made for me,
it's her fault.
And so that's perfect day because it doesn't take responsibility for his own
action and Firstie Gladesville,
Wilbon and then Ian Lakes broad,
right?
You might think that takes a fair bit of goal and then that's exactly right.
And this is relevant.
It's relevant because that's exactly what happened to this man in Toronto who
killed all those people.
First thing he did because of his painful self consciousness as plain white men.
And the second thing you did was bleeding a lot and the third was take his
revenge.
Okay,
so that's the next story.
So God been very happy with this because now the structure of Ba is permanently
disrupted by the emergence of self consciousness and their knowledge of death
and the emergence of the knowledge of good and evil.
It's like so much for that paradise,
right?
It's people have evolved beyond their childhood.
Harriet's same thing happens to the Buddha when he matures as fodder and links
in a walled city.
It's all where there's no agent has no depth and there's no sickness and he
grows up in there and everything's perfect,
but it gets curious and he goes outside the walls of the city and the first
thing he encounters is sickness.
And then he encounters old age and a different voyage in any encounters.
And when he encounters get it never goes back inside the walled city,
his orders and eight,
four it's exactly the same idea.
So Alien,
race and God as long now to take shop,
you know,
you've really done it.
Here's what's going to happen.
You knew about the future and now you're going to have to work because as soon
as you know about the future,
then you have to work.
Because even if things are going well now,
that doesn't mean they're going to go well in a monk and you better get ready
for that.
You better get ready for the then get ready for your old age,
then get ready for the fact that you might get hill and so you're working on,
that's that human beings work.
We work because we're aware of the future.
He tells eve while you're in trouble too,
and I won't go into this in too much detail,
but part of each trouble is that she's going to give birth to intelligence,
large skull and tiny dependent children,
and they're going to tear her apart and shelter and she's going to have to be
dependent on her husband.
And so those are the dual curses of whatever we get to wake up so well with the
world.
And that's what history starts as far as the biblical stories are concerned.